This thing on?
Hey miss Potts,
if you find this recording...
Don't feel bad about this
Part of the journey is the end
Just for the record, being adrift in space with zero promise of rescue is more fun than it sounds
Food and water ran out...
four days ago......
Oxygen'll run out tomorrow morning
and that'll be it
When I drift off,  I will dream about you
It's always you
Thanos did...
exactly what he said he was gonna do....
He wiped out.....
50 percent...
....of all living creatures..
We lost....
all of us.
We lost friends...
we lost family....
We lost a part of ourselves....
This is the fight of our lives
This is gonna work Steve.
I know it is.
...cause I don't know what I'm gonna do if it doesn't
Hi uh, is anyone home?
This is Scott Lang
we met a few years ago...
at the airport..
in Germany??
I got really big
Is this an old message?
Ant-Man? Ant-Man- I know you know- I know you know that
It's the front door
That's me. Can you buzz me in?
Holy crap everybody, they really dropped the Avengers 4 trailer
So we got to break it down...
...and they revealed the title is Endgame.
We guessed that like 6 months ago
So I'll talk about that
There are a couple of Easter eggs
and things the characters have said in previous movies like age of Ultron
then also, Doctor Strange
during infinity war.
There's a new round of that Imax ticket giveaway too -
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave your favorite moment from the trailer on the video.
First big thing
Tony Stark stuck in outer space on a ship on his way back from
Titan recording a message on his helmet,
now the reason why he thinks he's gonna die is because he's run out of food and he's
Slowly running out of power
the power unit in his helmet probably has like enough juice so that if someone finds him,
he turns it off
if someone finds him they can turn it on
They'll get that message
and they can take it back to earth if there are nice people like
whoever finds him
So there are a couple people in deep space right now that we know are gonna show up during Avengers 4 that could rescue him
Namely Captain Marvel who's gonna be on her way back to Planet Earth
so you have to remember the Titan is in this part of space and
Captain Marvel is probably somewhere in Kree and Skrull space
which is a little bit further away. Titan is in the black quadrant
That's sort of like where Thanos rules in outer space
So it remains to be seen whether or not she takes a stop by to pick him up on the way back home
But in order to do that, she'd have to pick up some sort of distress signal
So either he'd have to figure something out or if you wanted the WTF explainer
He'd have to find some way to extend his life force using his technology
So the whole thing about Tony Stark is that he solves unsolvable problems. He's a genius
So obviously he's gonna MacGyver himself out of this situation
But on top of that I also think it'll mean somebody coming back to pick him up
and don't forget that because we have ant-man
Showing up outside the Avengers facility. -"Hey, you remember me?
We met at Germany a while ago"- after he spent all of ant-man and the wasp
telling the wasp that he was best friends with Captain America-
"If the cap needed help-
-' cap ' ????
-tain America.....captain...
cap
its...
Its what we call him..
You can actually use the quantum realm to travel across
Space-time so they could actually either open a Bifrost using thor directly to him.
They might destroy the ship
so if thor could somehow pinpoint his ship and then
Bifrost right outside it so that he doesn't blow it up whenever he lands.
There are a couple different ways
They could find him with a couple different characters
But part of the intro is him speaking to the fans in general
Because part of the journey is the end....
....like this is the end of the first ten years of Marvel Studios
the first twenty two
films
So for a lot of these characters, it's meant to be their last big movie,
but we know we're getting a black widow movie
we know that Thor is probably gonna come back and guest star in other people's movies
again in the future if they don't do a
Direct 'Thor 4'  right away
But I love the dust title transition on the Marvel Studios title
to Thanos' farm with the Scarecrow of his armor from the 'Infinity Gauntlet' book
in him walking through his farm
The Russo's actually clarified where this planet is too-
so just in general
dust is a theme of the trailer they talk about the people that were dusted in the way the
Avengers title forms at the end the logo,
it's all the dust forming back into the title and because of Captain America's
Voice over while that's happening-" I don't know what we're gonna do
If this doesn't work"-, it's basically them undusting everyone and reforming all of humanity
But the whole idea with Thanos on his farm
is that this planet the Russo said behind the scenes they called
Titan 2- so it's not exactly the original Titan but it's like he's going back to his home planet
so this is a version of what Titan looked like
but on the set of the movie they called it Titan 2- when they were
Developing and shooting all this stuff.
The gauntlet is still charred
So I'm assuming that this isn't too long after we see him sit down on his farm
But the Russos said that because his chest wound had healed they implied that some time had passed
they didn't say exactly how much time,
but it wasn't like a linear progression of him snapping everyone out of existence,
then going talking to Gamora inside the soul world of the soul gem
and then going straight to his farm
You get the black widow voice over at the New Avengers Facility
with all the surviving original Avengers
-not including Iron Man who's still stuck in outer space
Captain America has shaved his beard and come home....
Like where are you going cap? I'm going home
I love that Bruce Banner here is looking at the picture of ant-man..
because they don't know that he's stuck in the quantum realm
we get the reveal at the end of the trailer,
but you also have Spider-Man (Peter Parker) over here, too
And they're just all in grief still kind of crying like even Captain America is crying
Thor doesn't have any voice over but it looks like he's just completely broken because get this heartbreaking
revealed that the Russos also teased, They said-
"Thanos showed up at the beginning of infinity war, killed half the
Asgardians to try and get the space stone from Loki...
but then after he snapped everyone out of existence another
50% of the Asgardians were cut
So he's left with 25% of the original Asgardians that he had at the end of Thor Ragnarok
So yes
There's still some Asgardians with which to create new Asgard
but he's lost most of his people and he's lost his brother Loki
So he like he's just sitting there grumbling like he's super pissed off and not sure what to do
They sort of hit all the beats of the big
surviving characters when they're talking about people who have lost someone that they care about and
Nebula is thinking about Gamora in this moment here.
Then when Captain America says we lost friends, We lost family...
We finally get the Hawkeye Ronan reveal as Black Widow goes to Japan
to find him in full Ronan gear with a katana
Wiping what looks like blood off of it right out of the comics
confirming that Hawkeye has become Ronan because his family was dusted
because remember how they explained during
Infinity war then during ant-man and the wasp is that
he and Scott Lang took the deal because their families couldn't handle them being on
The run with Captain America's Secret Avengers
so he'd hung up his bow completely, but look at him now
He is - PISSED OFF...
when Captain America is talking to Black Widow
here on the Quinn jet saying that-
"I don't know what we're gonna do if this doesn't work"....
he's wearing his Winter Soldier uniform
So he's put that back on but he shaved his beard off and I love that
They have the compass with Peggy Carter in it...
because that's something from the original Captain America movie and you know
There are a lot of theories about how Captain America might go out in this movie
They might find some way to bring
Peggy back around
because of all the B.A.R.F.'ing technology
and the rumors about time travel, Alternate universes
We're going to be revisiting a lot of moments in previous Avengers films
then we get the logo with all the dust being formed back into the 'A'..
like they are reforming the Avengers (1)
(2) and they reforming half of all life in the universe
Because you have to imagine that if they're gonna fix all the people that they've lost
it's gonna be a solution that'll fix everything that Thanos did
so the fact that Scott Lang shows up to the end in that funny tag implies that quantum energy and the
Quantum realm is the key to bringing everyone back
But obviously.....
there's really no reference to Captain Marvel anywhere in this..
so I wouldn't expect to see her
Genuinely in a trailer till like the next big one...
and that probably a couple months away because her movies coming out at the beginning
Of March, so maybe another Avengers 4 trailer right before that
But if you don't remember
here are all the times the characters have said the words "endgame" in previous movies...
""We are the Avengers..
We can bust arms dealers all the live long day, but
that up there. That's
That's the endgame......
Tony....
....there was no other way....
....we are in the endgame now ....""
I Remember about six months ago. I did a video about that
I'm like, you know what endgame would be a really cool title,
but supposedly the Russos shot that down
So even though I'm not convinced that there are a lot of fake Hulk type moments in this trailer
This all seems pretty genuine
Let me know in the comments if you think any of this footage is not
Actually going to appear during Avengers 4
Because it seems real even though some of it happens right after the end of infinity war.....
...and some of it seems like it happens
Much much later like when Scott Lang shows up
So what will happen is is we can freak out about this for the rest of the weekend
We're gonna get a Spider-Man Far From Home trailer
Saturday morning.
so I'll break that down as soon as it drops.
....no worries....
Leave your requests in the comments below
Especially if you have big questions about stuff that's in the trailer.
while you wait for everything,
click here for that brand new Captain Marvel Trailer....
....and click here for the brand-new Game of Thrones season 8 trailer.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everybody. Stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight.......